So let's look at our Tomasulo's Algorithm quiz solution.
Does it issue instructions in program order? Yes it does. Instructions come
from the instruction buffer in program order, and that's the order in which we
are going to issue them. You cannot issue instructions out of order.
So this is true. We don't select it because the question is, which is not true.
It dispatches instructions in program order, no it doesn't!
Instructions can [INAUDIBLE] be dispatched outside of program order,
that's why this is an out of order processor. So, this is definitely not true.
And then, it writes results in program order. Not necessarily. Again,
results can be written in the order in which they are produced, and it works for
that. So this is not true. So basically the one that is true is one.
The other two are not true so we selected two and three as not true.